between breath of the wild splatoon -
and mario karta deluxe intend Oh has
released enough high quality switch
games to keep you happy for the rest of
2017 but there are also plenty of other
developers with great games on switch
that you may have overlooked believe it
or not there are excellent platformers
racing games and retro adventures
waiting for you on the eShop to make
finding these a little bit easier we've
pinpointed some of our favorites here's
a look at six of the best hidden gems on
switch that we think you should play
Cave Story was one of the early indie
gems when it debuted on PC back in 2004
and its popularity there eventually led
to console and handheld ports including
a 3d remake for 3ds Nintendo switch is
the most recent recipient of Cave Story
and it's version is packed with all the
features diehard Cave Story fans want
including sixteen by nine and four by
three aspect ratios and alternate
soundtracks but why all the excitement
over a game that appears pretty simple
from the outside looking in well keep
story delivers personable characters and
familiar retro action in an 8 meet
16-bit world though clearly inspired by
select Metroid and Castlevania games
cave stories spirit is distinct and
positively quaint and with its arrival
on switch it finally gets the physical
release it deserves complete with a
full-color manual and soundtrack among
other packed in goodies even though
f-zero seems all but discontinued
Nintendo fans aren't entirely out of
luck when it comes to high speed racing
games in comes fast rmx an upgraded port
of we use fast racing neo this fast
futuristic racing game offers 30 tracks
and 15 vehicles as well as online and
local multiplayer options and it
features both shield and boost mechanics
that closely mirror f-zero in practice
no it doesn't have captain falcon but
fast rmx manages to capture the
thrilling speed and to an extent the
attitude of f-zero GX with a little
influence from the wipeout series style
of graphic design
severed is a traditional
dungeon-crawling RPG with modern
sensibilities its mechanics favorite
touchscreen devices not simply for the
sake of convenience but to facilitate a
combat system with demanding enemies
that must be cut in the right location
at the right time with a well-placed
swipe of your finger on switch severed
gets a slight upgrade from the Vita
version in a big upgrade from the iPhone
version thanks to the system's larger
display beyond the clever integration of
touchscreen controls and traditional
gameplay sevard presents the fascinating
tale of Sascha a one-armed warrior with
a magical sword who's caught in a
hellish dreamscape in search of her
loved ones the monsters Sasha faces are
creatively nasty accentuated by
developer drink box Studios easily
identifiable visual style with sharp
edges and expressive use of color it's
no surprise then that sevard makes a
strong first impression but it's not a
fluke the game is just as intense to
play as it is to look at it's everything
you'd expect from a dungeon crawler but
thanks to drink boxes inventive spirit
it's also packed with interesting motifs
and ideas that you never see coming
[Music]
shovel knight is 8-bit gaming not as it
was glitchy and fuzzy but as we choose
to remember pixelated vibrant and
cleverly detailed the sequel by
expansion specter of torment is a
similar retro action platformer that is
by all appearances on par with the
original the key difference is at the
star the lead character you control is a
villain from the first game Spectre
Knight his identity obviously plays into
a narrative differently than shovel
Knights did but more importantly Spectre
Knight moves and attacks in new ways too
this is all to say that Spectre of
torment is an excuse to revisit shovel
Knights wonderfully nostalgic world and
undergo a new range of challenges that
call upon a unique set of skills and the
reason it's worth playing at all is
because developer Yacht Club games work
rises above the team's inspirations and
ultimately our rose-tinted memories of
the past as well if you see any value at
all in classic 2d platformers shovel
knight and specter of torment will more
than likely make your day
wonderboy the dragons trap is a game
that sets out to bring the retro
platforming adventuring series to the
present day while also celebrating its
beginnings in the classic era as a full
remake of the original Wonder Boy three
for the Sega Master System in turbo
graphics the new version features a
brand new art style that's lush and
vivid giving off a greater depth in its
atmosphere along with fully orchestrated
soundtrack based on the original music
in keeping with its respect for the
original the remake allows you to shift
between classic and modern styles of
music and graphics on the fly if you
like playing the original game in HD you
can do that but if you're feeling crazy
you can mix things up and play with
modern graphics along with retro sound
and music it even allows all passwords
from the classic game to be used again
just like the good old days
wonderboy the Dragons trap is a
wonderful send up to the classic era
while showing that retro titles still
hold up incredibly well to this day
mechanically thumper is a simple call
and response game with added layers of
complexity as you complete subsequent
stages spiritually thumper is a
disturbance it heaves and crashes with
unbridled intensity but tracks that grow
faster and type signatures more
irregular the deeper you venture into
its well of madness call it dramatic but
this is the effect thumpers relentless
speed and atmosphere can have on a
person the perfect argument to give the
game a try they say music soothes the
savage beast but in thumpers case music
makes way for the savage beast within us
all play it on a TV play it with your
switch pressed up against your face
however you can play thumper woof where
was I
oh yeah this has been our look back at a
few of the amazing but underappreciated
games that came out on an Tendo switch
this year be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot for access to the latest twitch
news and reviews as they arrive and keep
an eye out for similar videos coming for
other platforms including PlayStation 4
Xbox one and PC thanks for watching
[Music]